mesdames messieurs bon dimanche rares
sont les moments où tous les partis sont
unanimes
Ottawa la semaine dernière une question
a fait consensus les dirigeants de
Hockey Canada doivent démissionner si
l'organisation veut survivre gestion
douteuse de cas d'agression sexuelle
réserve financière pour des dommages et
discrètement les victimes pour éviter
surtout que les agresseurs ne se
retrouvent sur la place publique des
témoignages d'un comité bien maigre en
regret et en excuse tous les partis sont
d'avis que le lien de confiance avec les
Canadiens est rompus et que seul un
renouvellement complet de l'équipe de
direction peut permettre d'envisager le
profond changement de culture nécessaire
au sein de l'organisation le député
conservateur Richard Martin une vision
particulière du dossier l'ex entraîneur
a œuvré pendant 21 saisons dans la Ligue
2 hockey junior majeur du Québec j'ai
discuté avec lui de la crise chez Hockey
Canada
Richard Martin bonjour bonjour je
m'appelle vous êtes député de Chicoutimi
le faire mais j'avais envie de vous
parler aujourd'hui comme ancien coach de
hockey avec tout ce qu'on voit au comité
parlementaire du patrimoine et les
dirigeants de Hockey Canada ok Canada
pour vous là c'est quoi qui Canada ok
Canada puis l'Équipe Canada Junior c'est
le rêve c'est le rêve de toutes les gens
qui sont impliqués dans leur hockey que
ce soit les entraîneurs que ce soit les
joueurs tu as été votre rêve à vous
absolument on veut tous c'est tout faire
partie de hockey Canada on veut tous
faire partie de l'équipe Canada Junior
on veut être dans le programme de Hockey
Canada alors c'est le rêve quand tu es
jeune tu veux représenter le Canada au
mondial alors c'est très gros puis
ensuite de ça ça des répercussions à
travers à travers le monde quand je suis
allé coacher entraîner en Suède les gens
nous voient gros au Canada parce qu'ils
savent que notre programme est excellent
extraordinaire puis on perd forme
qu'est-ce qui est en train de se passer
quand vous avez vu les témoignages de
Madame scanner la semaine dernière
vous avez pensé quoi mais premièrement
ce qui se passe OK le Canada c'est
triste puis moi aujourd'hui vous
m'invitez je vais en parler mais c'est
pas c'est pas un dossier mais
intéressant c'est aussi c'est décevant
on pensait pas ça là que une partie de
notre argent à l'inscription à l'aide
dans des fonds pour régler des dossiers
d'allégation d'allocation sexuelle
ensuite de ça on a appris qu'il y a deux
fonds alors ça arrête pas présentement
ok Canada puis
c'est là qu'on se dit on a commencé tout
ça ça fait des années on n'était pas au
courant puis là c'est certain que ça
termine l'image de Hockey Canada on a vu
le témoignage de Madame skeneur c'est en
seulement des fois s'ils sont
déconnectés parce que moi je me promène
dans ma circonscription
si on donne notre argent pour aller
là-dedans ça a pas de sens
découragé puis là quand on entend des
témoignages maintenant
à défendre ok Canada à n'importe quel
prix
est-ce qu'il y en a une option où on
pourrait garder les dirigeants qui sont
là présentement aucune option aucune
option tu peux pas il y a plus de
confiance en fait
pas méchant en disant ça c'est un coach
et quand je dis il y a plus d'options on
le remplace quelqu'un qui qui a fait des
erreurs pendant son passage c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne c'est c'est out
puis on pense à autre chose puis ça
prend une nouvelle restructuration ça
prend des nouvelles personnes pour aller
chercher la confiance parce que les
commanditaires ce sont détachés donc au
Canada c'est grave là il y avait tout ce
qu'il y avait de plus gros
commanditaires Tim Horton est ainsi de
suite là qui s'affichait au Canada on
voit Crosby on voit d'autres vedettes
faire des promotions alors la
présentement qu'est-ce qui peut la
confiance peut-elle revenir s'il y a du
monde nouveau là-dedans on peut regarder
ça c'est quasiment impossible puis moi
je dirais que il ne faudrait pas donner
d'argent à Hockey Canada tant tu es
aussi longtemps que les personnes sont
en place c'est comme ça laisse ta place
on pense à autre chose le désabus Hockey
Québec la semaine dernière c'est gros
c'est
emboîter le pas ça c'est un signal ça
veut dire que ok Québec
c'est qu'à un moment donné la pression
les parents qui ont pas d'argent pour
inscrire leur enfant à l'école les
parents ils n'ont pas d'argent pour
acheter du stock de ok les parents qui
font un autre sport mais qui aimeraient
leur enfant aimeraient de jouer au
hockey qui sont pas capables à prendre
que la moitié de l'argent qui s'en va
dans des fonds comme ça alors il y a de
la pression est-ce qu'il y a un travail
à faire au-delà de Haki Canada vous avez
été comme vous avez derrière l'été
dernièrement il y en a eu il y en a eu
des des jeunes hommes des garçons là qui
que vous avez dû garder sur le droit
chemin on le tu échappé quelque part un
moment donné quelqu'un quelque part qui
l'a échappé
écoutez on parle
je peux pas parler pour l'encadrement on
a toujours pensé qu'à ok Canada c'était
très rigide encadré énormément leur
athlète leur joueur de hockey
mais je vous dirai que où on a de la
difficulté à comprendre ok parce que là
je parle de junior ou ce qui s'est passé
c'est des joueurs qui sont choisis à
travers les équipes c'est des joueurs
les plus disciplinés les plus
responsables c'est des lieux de l'équipe
souvent c'est des capitales d'équipe
c'est là qu'on est préoccupé on entend
des histoires comme ça parce que ça
devrait être des modèles pour la joue
certains de ces joueurs là vous les avez
vu passer vous absolument mais aussi
c'est en début d'année il y a des
conférences moi je me souviens dans les
années où je dirigeais mais là on
parlait de il y avait des drogues il y
avait les initiations qu'il faut là que
ça arrête il y avait l'école aussi alors
il y a des gens qui venaient nous parler
un des intervenants la GRC mais nous
parler sur les drogues dures ici
informer
les stéroïdes prenaient des stéroïdes
alors c'était ça dans ce temps là mais
la minute que c'est conférence là sont
passées il faut l'entraîneur quand même
un job à faire de continuer à
à revenir ces sujets là durant l'année
juste pour être certain que c'est les
joueurs ou ça gagne comprennent bien le
message ce qu'on a banalisé d'après vous
dans le milieu du hockey la question des
agressions sexuelles c'est que écoutez
monsieur Schmitt a dit que c'est un à
deux cas par année on a demandé madame
présentement
on peut on comprend on comprend pas il
peut avoir des cas isolés mais quand ta
répétition comme ça on dit voyons non ce
qui se passe
ça fait pas de sens moi je suis peiné là
et déçu qu'est-ce qui va rester de
Hockey Canada à la fin tout ça d'après
vous la présentement ce nuage noir
au-dessus de Canada moi je vous dis que
si fait maison nette
il y a une nouvelle restructuration il y
a des choses qui qui sont différentes il
y a une volonté de changement de culture
parce que là je commence une culture je
suis bien d'accord qu'on protège les
victimes il faut la protéger mais on
protège tout la victime puis il y a pas
d'imputabilité envers les gens qui font
les actes comment tu veux après c'est
une roue qui tourne je pense que si il y
a des nouvelles personnes
structuration la conscience va venir peu
à peu les commanditaires vont revenir et
je pense qu'on va pouvoir aller de
l'avant tant que les gens sont en place
moi je vois pas la lumière au bout du
tunnel Richard Martel coach député merci
beaucoup